yeah yeah I used to just could wrap it
back around people like I dunno certain
people that I have to be around
sometimes that I can't stand but I I
have to do it yeah for example when I go
back to Sacramento and I kick it with a
bunch of my friends there's just one or
two people who I could give a [ __ ] less
do they wrote do they still annoy you
and [ __ ] all the [ __ ] time they just
say the dumbest [ __ ] things and I
have to sit there and just be like
whatever it's not worth it for me to
cause a scene and you know just make fun
of this person to trash them and at a
holiday that's the hardest part is like
when you can't roast them yeah because I
think that's always been my thing like
if someone annoys me I can just like
shut them down
yeah but then then I'm like ah well that
kind of makes me feel weird because then
when you get that they can't control
that yeah and then you know also too
it's just you know at a certain point
when do I start becoming an [ __ ]
because I have a problem with like
disliking somebody in like and I I just
can't hide it very well you know but
everybody else is very good at disliking
somebody and hiding it and yeah and my
thing was this is how I feel it is you
know we're adults now we're not in high
school if you don't like this person you
don't have to invite them over to the
stuff and you know their response is
like well we don't want that feeling
support you don't like them why do you
care I guess not everybody is just built
like that they just like to keep their
eating everything copacetic I think
that's why people aren't they stay
unsuccessful mmm I mean like a lot of
people they care see here's the thing
man validation from others is a huge
thing that humans need yeah what yeah
and I think that's the number one reason
or not the only reason but that's a big
reason why a lot of people just cannot
be successful yeah like you hear all
these [ __ ] Asian kids talking about
how all my parents don't like they don't
accept my passion so they don't even try
to do what they want to do yeah it's
like because they need the validation
first from their parents to pursue
whatever it's like it's your career you
you shouldn't have to answer to nobody
you just [ __ ] do it amen my mom said
it the best to me
at the end of the day your choices are
your choices yeah what I died you're
left with your choices that's it that's
very smart woman yeah I mean like even
think about like like like females right
like within their group it's so
important for that group to accept the
boyfriend mmm cuz I don't know any
relationships that last where the girl
group does not accept a boyfriend yeah
that that validation is so important you
know like all this stuff is all this
stuff is so important like if you don't
if you don't if you don't like what do
you call it if you're not capable of
just being okay with your own thoughts
and not being swayed by the opinions of
others like people won't get very far
yeah they'll just stay in their own
group of friends they're gonna stay
because then you'll be too scared to do
something different and be rejected by
your friends be rejected by your family
and you'll just be stuck and people say
like you know poor people they're gonna
pop out poor people middle class people
are gonna pop out middle class people
because it's the it's the sphere of
influence right yeah the people that
you're around and it sucks because going
back to this guy situation like a lot of
people are dealing with so much stupid
pointless [ __ ] that's filling up their
mind that they're not really killing it
in life cuz let's say like 80% of their
thoughts are on stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] like
this yeah and then the other twenty is
probably on their dreams or something
yeah yeah it's it's it's really like
where you want to spend your energy man
like I'm starting to understand that
more today huh [ __ ] funny that we're
talking about this because my you know a
yeah your managers yeah so I you know
his girlfriend too was talking about a
story just like how like in the past she
had to deal with a few people and she
gets like so revved up when she talks
about she's reliving it yeah oh [ __ ]
like I said I told oz I bet you got
[ __ ] hate in your heart dude yeah you
get hyped up and revved up about just
kind of ridiculous [ __ ] that shouldn't
affect you so she's not letting go [ __ ]
yeah and also too it's like within a
conversation to like some
when you have a disagreement with things
you have to really think about why is it
really bothering you why what for what
reason and also the the concept of
picking and choosing your battles really
comes into play when you become an adult
right yeah so for example she was
talking about how Mac I forgot who who
this person was but where she was
talking about semantics right where
there was an argument about a definition
of a word and that was causing a spark
to fight about it's like does it really
[ __ ] matter about she was trying to
look for validation yeah it's another
thing of humans needing validation yeah
so she probably wanted you to [ __ ]
agree
so she's I knew us right I knew it yeah
that [ __ ] but if that's not how you say
[ __ ] tomahto
yeah it's tomato [ __ ] yeah you
know it's like the I'm right you're
wrong type of stuff and how many hours
does she spend thinking about that [ __ ]
it's a waste a lot of people do this
exactly I am guilty of it for most of my
life and a lot of funny [ __ ] came out of
it but also a lot of [ __ ] time was
wasted yeah man and I wish I caught on
this [ __ ] sooner because I'm a [ __ ]
kill it cuz I'm like I don't have no
[ __ ] like I can catch this [ __ ]
and I thought like people think we're
killing it now man just [ __ ] wait
till we [ __ ] learn how to control
this [ __ ] yeah I think I think a lot of
people who are very successful also know
how to control their emotions because
they understand how to control their
situation very well yeah when I get
upset and I get angry I can't work and
it mean either devastates me oh no it
devastates me and it hinders me from
progress which I hate yeah whenever
Marilyn I get into a fleshie out there
right now whatever and I get into a
fight I'm [ __ ] for the whole day alright
look for three days angry man I get I
get caught up in my feelings man and I'm
just sitting there just thinking like I
can't go to I can't go to sleep I can
eat for sure I can't go to don't worry I
don't affect my appetite I can't sleep I
can't focus I can't I can't function